at google cloud we continue to design
refine and iterate our experience so
that you can be as productive as the
world demands and we've heard from you
all that the google cloud dashboard
could use some improvements
our existing dashboard presents graphs
links to documentation and news and
though this information is helpful we
know that we could do a little bit
better
we've heard that the homepage needs to
be fast simple and helpful for getting
back to recently used products and as
they say sometimes less is more
so we designed a new homepage on google
cloud for simplicity performance and
navigation the new page gives you a
clean and streamlined experience that
helps you navigate to your most relevant
destinations the streamline ui also
helps you stay organized and is designed
to help you complete your task you can
find this page by heading straight to
console.cloud.google.com and signing it
the new home page includes
a clean header that clearly displays the
project you're working in with the
ability to copy the project number and
id with a click of a button
actionable recommendations to better
secure your environment or help reduce
spending
key actions to quickly create a compute
engine vm gke cluster or storage bucket
or run a query in bigquery
quick access to head straight to your
most used product pages and this is
based on featured products or content
you recently viewed across all your
projects enabled by google cloud ml
powered active assist
and a link to the all products page that
showcases all of the google cloud
products and key partner products in one
easy to navigate place
and lastly links to the original
dashboard page
our goal is to give you clear actionable
information and reduce the time it takes
to get to your most relevant
destinations with the new page layout
you'll know exactly which organization
and project you're working in which is
useful for those of you operating under
multiple organizations or projects or in
larger resource hierarchies with key
action buttons at the top you no longer
need to go to the product page first to
do common tasks like spinning up a vm or
gke cluster
the new home page loads approximately 40
faster than the dashboard the new
homepage also reduces the time for you
to navigate we're seeing people navigate
up to 43 faster this means that from the
time you head to the homepage you're
able to head to your destination or task
faster than the project dashboard
to give you a customized experience
we're surfacing your most relevant
product pages based on what you've
recently viewed via quick access powered
by active assist quick access gets you
back to your previous task or to a
portion of the console that you visit
frequently you can quickly head straight
to those pages without scrolling through
the side menu
and quick access is a cross project view
to help you switch back to a page you
were impossibly in another project this
is one of our first cross project views
so yes let us know how you like it to
further simplify your experience and
ensure consistency across our products
google cloud platform is now called
google cloud in addition the moba app
name previously called cloud console app
is renamed to google cloud app and
you'll see this update reflected across
most of our website and documentation
we hope that you find the new homepage a
simplified smooth and improved
experience and of course if you have any
feedback or suggestions reach out to me
at steph r underscore wong oh and join
us on a twitter space at the google
cloud tech handle on june 23rd to learn
more about this new page from our
product team
if you're interested in developer news
and tools check out our developer center
and join google cloud innovators this is
stephanie wong i'll see you all next
time